alertée la livre allait rester cool on
attend encore fait la bise aussi au
revoir havas est costaud c'est
incroyable maintenant je vois ça j'ai
peur je vois même certains l'utilisent
et déjà sur des jobines donc ça prouve
que tu peux le prendre en déplacement
mais tu peux t'amuser que même temps
c'est bien
ouais aussi tu peux donc si on est
honnête monsieur là pour protéger lui et
spe voilà exactement ça c'est là quand
tu deviens youtuber s'élève toujours à
tourrettes bronze aime vraiment le gros
coup de foudre sur le manifeste
principalement oui ça a été
[Musique]
cb
mais c'est vrai
on aujourd'hui au studio rochon à paris
pour en parler de panasonic des nouveaux
produits de panasonic est ce un s1 r il
ya du nouveau chez pana gars des
hybrides qui franchement sont justes et
non envoie du bois ce que je propose
c'est d'aller faire un petit tour et
puis ensuite on verra contre l équipe de
pas d'actes on our expliqué tu peux ses
produits comprendre l'adn bonjour un
petit peu ce qu'on peut faire avec ces
produits toutes les nouveautés vous
allez y va franchement c'est juste
énorme
est-ce qu'on n'est pas bien ici je
devrais me trouver un petit dieu comme
ça pour tourner et voilà alors oui
bonjour il ya des nouveaux du nouveau
aussi pana et me dire exactement ce que
c'est et oui exactement on sort deux
boîtiers l1 et sa r ouais
nouveauté chez panasonic c'est du plein
format donc du 24 36 sans compromis
on va dire que en gros tous le savoir
faire et l'expertisé lumix depuis toutes
ces années sur l'hybride je rappelle
c'est quand même un hacker lancé
l'hybride en 2008 bon on l'a mis dans le
joujou c'est à dire allez on va faire
simple double stabilisation c'est à dire
ces habitations capteur plus optique les
de travailler ensemble
bon en photo ou en vidéo c'est à ces
mêmes a aujourd'hui un record - et son
jazz cinq exactement
ouais je dirais même un poil plus
performant encore que sur le gh1 quand
je marchais bien là dessus un monstre en
vidéo alors le s1 est plus orienté vidéo
que le s1 r parce que le s1 fait 24
millions de pixels à un salaire en fait
47 dont il y en a un qui blesse un
normal et plus orientée
vidéo oui le monde ni aux pixels c'est
moins compliqué pour faire de la 4k par
exemple ça va permet d'aller beaucoup
plus loin
d'ailleurs les deux sont capables de
faire du slow motion en full hd jusqu'à
180 images seconde en 4k jusqu'à 60 où
il y en un terrain ouest avec
l'accaparent il fallait veulent calcul
est dedans on est sur un appareil qui
est un robuste
en gros ça ressemble à un hub à sa
faveur robert qui résiste à tous j'ai vu
des vidéos vous n'étiez dans le feu dans
la glace ou l'instant ils auraient loupé
ça nous serons assurés officiellement il
résiste à -10° à +40 résistant à la
pluie poussière froid chaud il n'y a
qu'à peu près tout et pour l'avoir
éprouvé oui c'est impressionnant
[Musique]
mais je
ça va je viens bonjour à tous bonjour je
viens rabreau ça va yes c'est ça bon
qu'est ce que tu en penses de série 20
écoutez moi je suis plutôt agréablement
surpris puisque ça fait un an que je
bosse avec du ghb pièces et c'est vrai
que au bout d'un an d'utilisation tu
vois le gaultier toujours cool mais tu
as envie d'aller plus loin quant à lui
de 2 pouvoir shooter en low light etc
ouais là je les prie et rapidement en
main et franchement ça annonce du très
très beau et très lourde la montée en
iso à 2800 sabri pas donc ça c'est super
cool ouais moi il ya un truc qui me
choque l'un venant du g15 c'est le poids
ouais mais ça peut être un avantage
comme un inconvénient donc je demande à
tester sur le terrain
là je pourrai pas le faire tu voit
typiquement déjà là j'ai un peu mal que
je reste un peu de mes attentes
c'est ça les mecs costauds tu les
reconnaître et les chaînes les boîtiers
mourir lui et de transport en deux mots
je pense que tu as déjà parlé de tout ça
moi je le trouve je le trouve sur le
papier vraiment très très bon je trouve
un peu cher de l'autre côté derrière et
la techno donc c'est normal sur la site
trop grand public je l'aimais loire -
certainement le voir je reprends la
cible trop grand public j'ai toujours un
petit doute parce que ça coûte cher et
c'est un bel investissement vous pouvez
passer il n'y a pas de souci mais voilà
donc ce que c'est vraiment un très très
bel outil j'ai vraiment hâte de pouvoir
le tester et comme tu dis sur le point
d'y sont vraiment faible luminosité
pourra monter une sauce encore du bruit
je trouve que c'est vraiment le plus
doux mais ce que je regrette c'est pour
moi c'est pas adapté mais pour moi parce
qu'il me faudra un miroir comme honda
sur le côté ça c'est compliqué de savoir
ce qu'on peut pas la même selon le dg
j'ai pu tester pendant une semaine
sony le plein format sur la gamme alpha
on est pareil tu avais pas l'écran donc
au début c'est déroutant la [ __ ] c'est
compliqué comment je vais faire et
finalement tu fais confiance
en la machine ouais ça passe plutôt bien
tu vois et ça marche mais by j'ai très
hâte de tester en conditions réelles le
s1 ouais et aussi je pense
mais pouvoir pour voir on encore y est
bouleversé la vie allait rester cools et
attends je n'en fais la bise l'asie au
revoir havas ait salubrité le viseur et
le viseur aujourd'hui plus défini du
marché c'est à dire que en gros le
humain fait 6 millions pixels
numa moyens on va dire bon le viseur
fait 5 7 millions de pixels un oled
d'accord c'est un viseur qui est
quasiment proche de la vision humaine
très impressionnant les grands en plus
bien sûr ce qu'on voit dans un viseur
électronique c'est le principe de
l'hybride rappelle un hybride c'est ni
plus ni moins qu'un reflex ont attiré le
miroir bah c'est quelque chose que ce
que vous êtes concerné sur l'écran du
cool ou à l'écran au passage orientable
ou en les deux sens et même dans ce sens
là d'accord c'est costaud l'incroyable
moi quand je vois ça j'ai peur oui il ya
par contre si je le fais ces couples on
peut pas l'utiliser du coup en mode
votre blog alors en bon vieux youtuber
seul point il peut pas cela dit non en
effet mais par contre il est wi fi
bluetooth dont on peut avoir un retour
vidéo agoraphones la latence est infime
que le peut vraiment avoir un retour sur
le smartphone d'ailleurs le contrôler
entièrement depuis smartphone d'accord
et de toute façon la gelée mais qui au
passage une hdmi
taille normale plein format oui on la
branche sur une télé un moniteur un
écran n'importe quoi et on a le retour
vidéo en live avec ou sans les
informations pour ceux qui veulent faire
l'enregistrement sur des enregistreurs
externe
c'est possible d'un d'ailleurs juste à
côté un petit usb c est ce qui fait
alors évidemment ça permet des charges
et les photos c'est basique mais
alimentés et recharger le boîtier ça n'a
jamais été fait c'est à dire que je peut
l'alimenter et leurs chargeurs en même
temps donc si j'ai des soucis
d'autonomie je branche un groupe aux
banques derrière je recharge moitié en
même temps que moi c'est même sûr parti
pour des heures exactement cours parti
pour des heures du coup y'a logiciels
pour le piloter depuis l'ordinateur bien
sur wii sur ces choses là prise micro
prise casque ça paraît assez logique là
dessus
[Musique]
thomas romain ba ouais alors qu'est ce
que tu en penses nouveau boîtier de
panat récents et 100 m écoute j'ai alors
déjà pour être très honnête je les prie
en main uniquement 4 5 minutes
mais si j'ai fait quelques shoots avec
j'ai beaucoup de mal la visée en fait
par un écran numérique moi c'est quand
je fais de la photo
j'aime bien chercher mes réglages sans
avoir déjà le résultat via un écran
ouais donc déjà la photo avec un hybride
tel que celui ci pour moi ce serait
totalement nouveau donc j'en ai jamais
fait donc fait pas vraiment de donner
mon avis maintenant là où je reste ultra
conquis baissé par rapport à toutes les
performances de l'appareil et en vidéo
je trouve que c'est un appareil photo
qui justement comment ça a été je suis
fan de garonne avec l'inde et oui j'ai
aucune excuse je peux rien dire parce
qu'évidemment en terme de vidéo il ya
des supers bons résultats et puis voilà
juste l'écran amovible ou des choses
comme ça qui font que au oui tiens ces
pratiques tu vois tu rien donc non je
suis très content de ce qu'ils délivrent
en termes de performances et d'ergonomie
de ce que j'en ai vu pour l'instant même
si c'est totalement nouveau pour moi de
passer d'une ergonomie cannon à pana
c'est complètement différent totalement
mais c'est vrai qu'il a l'air cool et le
fort mais sympa ouais forme est assez
compact par rapport à ce que tu as été
très compact il est très compact et il
reste je trouve dans un poids
raisonnable
voilà et tu vois même certains
utilisaient déjà sur des jobines et
autres sauf que tu peux le prendre en
déplacement tu t'amuses que monde pense
à dire ouais aussi tu peux me sur le s1
en 24 25 et trompait pas de limite de
temps d'enregistrement
mais qu'a donc jusqu'à ce que ma carte
soit pleine ouais parce que des cartes
d'ailleurs double slot sd excuses des
excuses des cons passif cf express dont
on sait les futures cartes
professionnelles qui vont pas tarder à
arriver
ça veut dire que je fais ce que je veux
avec soin les enregistrements relais
soit la sauvegarde soit je mets la
moitié d'un copain la photo d'un côté la
vidéo de l'autre etc
je fais ce que tu veux mais comme tu me
tues fait part de ses inquiétudes les
touches sont rétroéclairées alors la
ville
lumière on s'en rend pas compte mais
l'écran sur le dessus et du coup
quelques touches sont rétroéclairées
date chacun
que te dire de plus des rafales alors en
photo conventionnelle jusqu'à neuf
images seconde en single six ans
continue et on a un mode historique chez
nous qui s'appelle le mode photo sica
qui permet de faire des photos à 18 me
en pixels mais 30 images par seconde sur
des durées extrêmement longue
d'accord ce qui est assez dément
là-dessus possibilité de verrouiller des
touches si on a besoin ses rangs nous
associe aussi professionnel j'ai envie
de dire il a vraiment un doublé
justement je me demande à qui ils
destinent au final pas en fait il ya
deux écoles on va dire oui le s1 tout le
monde
oui pour le coup celui qui veut
commencer à apprendre à faire de la
vidéo ou même quand on fait déjà de
façon un peu expert du fait de la
fameuse option qui va attention je vais
parler des langues bizarre on qui va
faire du 4 2 2 10 bits en interne sur le
24 25 30 et en externe sur le 50 60 et
avec une option pour 20 du log ou désolé
pour cela que j'ai pas qu'ils n'ont pas
compris ce que geneviève et ceux là vont
avoir besoin de ça ceux qui n'ont pas
compris ce que je viens de dire
ils feront déjà des vidéos
extraordinaire avec ce qui est
l'appareil est capable de faire en
interne ce qu'encore une fois sur le 24
25 ans qui a pas de crop la justice
toute la surface du capteur
la sensibilité est démente jusqu'à 12800
iso sur le s1 en adhérant du qui sont
démentiels en termes de bruit n'a pas un
peu de choses pas là dessus bien sûr on
peut monter plus haut sur ce boîtier
d'un prêt il ya tellement on dire en
fait cela il est pour tout le monde pour
tous ceux qui veulent plus orienté vidéo
c'est non c'est vraiment un jour le plus
long terme vidéo marche
d'accord il est vraiment mi-chemin pour
les deux ans photo même l'objectif de
kits d'origine démarche très très bien
avec un pic et là c'est incroyable je
suis là où monsieur madame tout le monde
le laissant air il fait 47 millions de
pixels donc il va beaucoup moins loin en
vidéo la fameuse option spéciale que
dont je parlais il peut pas la voir lui
par contre 47 millions de pixels du coup
les deux ont un mode haute résolution
par déplacement du capteur lui le s1 air
donc est capable de faire des photos
jusqu'à 187 millions pixels d'accord
officier les honneurs des photos des
manteaux en termes de qualité oui le et
s'alimente à 96 mais pour ceux qui font
du footing cros que veulent vraiment
faire de l'art car âge dans les photos
etc
le s1 est réunie magique parce que 47
millions pixels on peut faire à peu près
ce qu'on veut ce que tu veux y a pas de
limite exactement
baptiste chef perdu non monsieur tu vas
lanvollon les voitures ça va légaliser
écoute certains le laissent c'est
sacrément pattes c'est très loin du
défunt nouveau pas de toi oui donc si on
endette monsieur là pour te protéger lui
et experts voilà exactement ça c'est là
quand tu deviens youtuber s'est toujours
entouré de bons amis car là il a fait
jusqu'à là bien là et il arrive et
coûteux et coups de manche et de balayer
tout ce que tu veux
du professionnel justement du
photographe vidéaste sur ces nouveaux
appareils de panat alors vraiment le
gros coup de foudre sur le lundi 16
principalement ouais ça a été géré la
montée en iso c'était vraiment une
grosse surprise pour moi je m'attendais
pas du tout en réalité j'avais qu'ils
aillent plus sensible que que m mais
vraiment la montée en iso vraiment
extraordinaire dans le sens où par
exemple aujourd'hui j'ai travaillé toute
la journée
en définitive là où j'aurais placé
beaucoup plus de puissance
j'ai pu jouer que dix mais en fait mais
l'aide labour ne va du coup c'est moins
fatigant pour moi c'est moins fatigant
pour la fission pour tout le monde c'est
plus agréable
on est vraiment dans l'ambiance
finalement tamisée alors que normalement
j'aurais dû y avoir une débauche de
puissance et là j'ai tout shooté à 3200
iso
mon corps au centième de seconde parce
que j'étais à 50 images par seconde donc
pour respecter les règles du chanteur
etc
voilà donc j'étais quand même à 50
images par seconde au centième de
seconde ce qui définit déjà les choses
et puis après à 3200 iso dans ce cas là
est franchement pas du tout de monter de
bruit notamment normand et solidaire
j'ai eu l'occasion aussi de tester le r
et le s en studio et semaine dernière
avec lui mixte et heures donc en mode
connecté première j'irai expérience
justement du mode connecté puisque du
coup dans ce cas là en fait l'appareil
se recharge pendant le shooting ça c'est
quand même un énorme avantage donc non
seulement il ya un bypass complète de la
batterie
c'est vraiment le laptop ou lime rock
sur laptop qui prend le relais mais en
plus ça visiblement ils rechargent en
plus donc ça c'est vraiment un gros
avantage est alors au d'un point de vue
purement photo je me suis rendu compte
que le s1 assure vraiment vraiment aussi
en terme de qualité j'ai exporté après
en mai tiff en fait les deux alors c'est
sûr que l'air est mieux mieux mieux
équipés pour pouvoir faire du prix de
très très large mais pour une un visage
je dirais ordinaire franchement es
défend admirablement bien en termes de
budget on est on est où il est déjà au
delà disposent les produits sont en
train d'arriver donc là et il arrive en
magasin
en termes de budget ça va aller de je
vais prendre une plage large
c'est-à-dire le s est un boîtier nu aux
remises parce qu'il ya des remises au
lancement de 1500 euros ou l onu et ça
va jusqu'à des kits pour le dessin air à
4600 euros avec l'objectif d' accord
donc il ya pour tout le monde en
sélection qu'en terme d'objectifs
l'alliance les 3 lumix sigma les cas va
permettre d'avoir d'ici un an et demi
une quantité d'objectifs hallucinante
s'il m'a annoncé juste pour les optiques
avec cette monture la 11 objectif d'ici
quelques mois
nous on en a dix d'ici à 2020 en gros on
a plus de 70 objectif d'ici deux ans
c'est énorme mais ouais on a chaud avec
offerte c'est ça ok cool pour tout le
monde alors comment vous les trouvez ces
nouveaux s en est sa mère alors la
mannequin très bien le concert très bien
de ce que j'ai cru comprendre c'est que
la gamme g h ne disparaîtrait pas genre
ils sont pas là pour se planter les jazz
donc y aura de vrais h6 merci vous vous
tournez ou jose 4 avant de coacher h4
voilà exactement prix bonne bête
moi j'avais une question à jayson c'est
la nouvelle mode la barbe a la flemme en
fait je sais ce que c'est je comprends
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui
l'envoyé du boîtier qui sont vraiment
très intéressant c'est cool parce que
panasonic
on voit qu'il continue à occuper le
terrain avec des solutions qui sont
hyper hyper hyper intéressante j'espère
qu'on pourra tester prochainement vous
invite à faire une chose c'est bien sûr
à vous abonner comme ça on en parle
ensemble voilà vous embrasse nous prenez
soin de vous et à demain ciao